roland perez roland perret attaque les
étapes et jacky jacquet ossébi quichotte
qui s'est pas mis aussi cgdd non en fait
il a essayé d'appeler les [ __ ] et béni
oui oui c'est ma belle soeur oui
mais tu appelles ça s'est appelée oui
oui oui
[Rires]
c'est
ma belle-fille ouais
c'est du marguerite all about s'est
ainsi
à la sarre guérite ainsi c'est trop
drôle comme ça on peut faire la même
chose avec votre téléphone
[Applaudissements]
heureusement je n'ai pas le code
mais toi dis pas et tony g qui tony mené
le korsico un ami cyril hanouna et vous
a appelé deux fois que tu voulais
passer par l'egypte
alors est ce ça et il a fait sa mère
mais ça va c'est quand il appelle son
ventre maman maman c'est comme olive au
lit parce que
c'est ainsi qu'on allait engager la
maman de madame t'appelle beaucoup ton
fils julien castaldi ben je suis chez
lui ah ben je vais ta maman chérie ça
c'est la belle mère
maman chérie ce label mais oui oui jarre
curieuse méthode
minceur people oui bah oui j'ai une
grande soirée paquets vendus niveau
d'eau sama clémentine bien sûr que quand
ils doivent retirer leurs
cabines se ferait en deux heures la vie
ta douceur ses douces et de mes deux
garçons de la famille grand diamètre
danger un frère un frère ennemi
de un frère et deux soeurs et un frère
et deux soeurs et assurant là j'avais vu
clémentine maintenant et pas publics
d'aller sur les marchés
elle est productrice de l'émission
commence à peine son auteur
soit trouvée papaye
non c'est vrai bah oui pas lasser ou fin
mai elle va être kiné elle a quel âge à
la 24 ans non tu as une soeur de 24 ans
dans la wii mais dis-moi frère dans la
famille en fait c'est là dans les âges
au
printemps mais dans la vie de
castagniccia père de 25 ans
artiste 58
il était nominé deux fois moins vieux
que la vie c'est le cas d'affaires dans
les interviews nous comprendre les âges
de la value catane italie la gale 24
non je suis le groupe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a aucune logique dans les alpes sa
soeur de 24 ans est plus âgé que sa mère
non mais c'est une tare cas alors et ses
intrigues ne sera pas le tas maintiens
mon amour allemand ouais crois tu as un
amour mais non c'est un amour un amour
autrichien
à tailler en petits bouts
j'ai un amour guatémaltèques sont
d'abord il s'appelle mon amour allemand
d'accord avec mon amour kunter
d'ailleurs si ça répond pas à mon avis
c'est peu de chances si sa réponse
je peux tu
approches capable de monter les
rappels la femme de castaldi avec
montaigne vos attentions lors 06 se sait
tout cas tu as fan ne regarde même pas
les lasser l'heure où aller avec le
petit
sur le peu trop à tous avec elle
avec le petit surtout
[Musique]
la fête qu'est ce que tu fais c'est la
propriété ça ah ouais et marqué que je
vais te ramener la paix non non non non
répond même pas moins bizarre qu'il faut
dire à ta femme qu'elle est directe
à temps et c'est quoi ta femme master
sciences sociales 18h51 table qui ma
fille après sinon ton fils de 58 ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et qui parce que c'est celle qu'il
appelle faut qu'elle décroche après lyon
c'est très heureuse en cadeau lors qu'il
est logique dans les âges de la famille
chester dit qu'on pourrait avoir non
mais sans déconner vous avez un gars
comme as i lay le matin tu te réveilles
tu as un gars avec un times comme à
aucune logique frère sans déconner c'est
un truc de fou tient kaunas qui
m'appelle
c'est amer
non elle m'appelle va décrocher elle va
décrocher les prévenus j'ai pas donc
quand même pas quand même pas bien pas
de forcer
le critique sinon qu actuellement à
l'ohl or
hanouna cyril
fait des boulettes règles j'adore alors
si avec benjamin on est à l'antenne on
est en direct ouais donc pas quand on
parle pas de son kiki
il faut ça va pas du tout les cheveux là
le pot c'est grave là il fait une
réaction je lui propose de lui raser la
tête ce que chez les meilleurs riders de
tête un ballon gratté dos nu fernand
très court nous les faire très court je
te dis
il peut pas rester comme ça il ne peut
pas rester comme ça je te jure la
branche non mais non il faille bram ont
valu faire on va déjà lui couper parce
que voilà là c'est chaque chaque seconde
qui passe c'est un cheveu qui perd
sache le jeu c'est qu'il a déjà perdu de
couilles
j'aimerais pas tu vois non mais sans
déconner si tu te retrouves avec un
homme sans dieu sans cheveux sans
couilles à un moment j'ai pas ce que tu
vas faire un mois je te dis je dis ça
pour toi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] la merde
séries aurore chéries chéris que j'te
jure faut vraiment faire quelque chose
parce que j'ai peur pour lui c'est comme
je les aime et là je pense qu'il faut
vraiment mais normes on va lui laisser
quand même genre 1 cm
[Musique]
on lui laisse le laisse un centimètre
par centimètre une base militaire
mais alors dia ndiaye bah oui une
formule qui ressemble un dialogue un
gala c'est chelou la la la
il est ok si t'es ok c'est pour ça c'est
ça l'amour et je te dire tu vas barque
ou un mec comme ça qui dit si ma meuf
est ok choqué c'est majeur à gâter il
parle de lui il était ok allez version
les internautes y
arriver
merci aux montants moi ça le fait non
c'est bon c'est devant lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]